in the early hours of Saturday an
announcement that Sudan's military junta
and the opposition coalition had agreed
on how to govern the country they
fleshed out the details on the makeup
and functions of a transitional
government until elections in three
years I'm very pleased in the name of
the African mediation and two respected
delegations to declare to the Sudanese
people and the international community
that the two delegations have fully
agreed on the constitutional project the
reaction was immediate on the streets of
Khartoum announcing the deal African
Union in vuoi Muhammad Hassan labott
gave no detail about the contents of the
declaration he said talks are continuing
on how and when it would be signed
during the negotiations the military
council ceded two demands for justice
over the killing of at least six people
including four schoolchildren at a
protest earlier in the week nine
soldiers were detained it was a victory
for tens of thousands of Sudanese who
had marched demanding justice for the
deaths it was certainly a horrible
massacre we pray the situation improves
and that the right of the students are
not neglected blood for blood and
punishment is a must
[Applause]
protesters have been flexing their
muscles since December
frustration started with the economy
President Omar al-bashir was in their
crosshairs the number of protests grew
along with their demands until Bashir
was removed in the military coup in
April general setup a military council
the protesters demanded civilians take
the lead in the transition they started
a sitting outside the army headquarters
forcing military rulers to begin talks
over how to share power on June 3rd
security forces raid at that
demonstration they killed more than 100
people and injured many more talks
resumed a month later mediated by the
African Union in Ethiopia the first
breakthrough came on July 17 leading to
the signing of a political agreement
between the military junta and the
opposition coalition they agreed on an
11 person transitional council with
representatives from both sides and a
rotating leadership the disagreements
had remained over the wording of
constitutional changes now with the
details agreed and assigning eminent
Sudanese people have a roadmap to a more
peaceful future Shalit Bellis al Jazeera